[Music]
will you renfield take this woman baba
yaga
hi what is it you are wanting at our
wedding
you
what is that girl doing here she's some
sort of monster hunter
your new targets are messy the loch ness
monster and yeti
the snow monster of the himalayas we
have to stop her max no prepare me for
the fight mom he's gonna turn us all
into monsters again on this magical
monster night
oh great job max but how can we save
them if we don't know where they are i
can find anyone with this party people
disappear pronto
[Music]
that doesn't work on me i am perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
you are all crazy
okay that's not good
prince
[Music]
all right guys the quadratic formula
let the fun begin
who could tell me how the formula begins
x equals
[Applause]
no
no no
this isn't happening
what is that oh snap all right settle
down little goblins
[Music]
gotta get home
[Music]
[Music]
i'm calm
then
yes
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia was given their own magical
gifts
uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong
the donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with an arepa
[Music]
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
[Music]
let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
[Music]
a lot of stairs
but at least i'll have a friend nope he
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
emergency at the chemical factory no
georgia girls aren't allowed to be
firemen but i'm as brave as any boy
it's my dream it's my destiny
girls can't be firemen give me a break
[Music]
extra extra arsonist strikes again
the firemen
go into the theaters
they don't come out
i need you to run the fire investigation
i'll need a team here's the plan i
joined dad's team egg crate for the
stomach muscles mango for the biceps
and for the mustache
[Music]
okay too much
are you one of the volunteers
do i
know
let me you
you the brains of your operation ricardo
uh ginger driver fastest cabbie in
manhattan
who are you me uh i'm joe i'm diamond
joe slow down joe did you even check
this one
the water pressure
we're going in
seriously
it's funny
you remind me of my daughter huh really
yeah that is funny
yeah she wanted to be a fireman too
so why didn't you teach her what you're
teaching me she's my daughter i love her
and i worry about her every second of my
life
if i catch the arsonist i'll have to
change the rules then i'll be the first
fireman woman the job is far too
dangerous
maybe this is a sign that it's time you
follow your own dreams
i never gave up on mine
[Music]
the mustache is very convincing it's my
dog's butt hair
are you ready
this is the main event
he's coming
[Applause]
whoa
come get some of this
[Applause]
who wants a selfie spectacular i've got
your whole life story tattooed on my
body
yeah
in a long history of monster wrestling
there has never been a champion quite
like in texas fans around the world are
asking is there a challenger out there
with the hunger
the drive
the discipline to become the next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him did
he eat
thank you that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what
yeah that's gonna be a hard no for me
[Music]
oh this is my nightmare
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
behold the transformation ray awesome
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up johnny oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad
you're human drag oh no i have a total
dad bod
um what is going on
what's up
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
right
stereo man
wow flying as a monster is so much
better right
nervous liar huh
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious it's wondrous
it's burning my eyes
if we don't fix you guys through you'll
be like this forever seriously everybody
relax
just enjoy the view ah please
being a human is the worst dance
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun the only place to
experience transfer mania is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm surrounded by idiots
i am completely different from my family
why is she avoiding us they're both
growing up so fast pretty hot hey ladies
i have the very solution we are going on
a family vacation
let's roam
you've always wanted to see more of this
great country
right in the niagara falls
hi what's your talent
there's my little holy terror
i remember the night when say was born
it was a tuesday she was silent that's a
jellyfish and i put all the babies back
where i found them huh i think
[Music]
we need to stop that family so the truth
can come out
who is that man no one at all do you
this trip will bring the atoms closer
than ever before
or there will be no survivors
it's just us and the wonderful sound of
silence
[Music]
um
[Music]
it
good to see you my big whiskered cousin
i still don't understand the word that
guy says
[Music]
for thousands of years
the bond between my children and i
was perfect
now a dark presence threatens to destroy
the amazon
a young girl
holds the power to change even the
darkest heart
i'm the gimbal of kendama greatest
hunter in the whole amazon
rainbow you are a very special person
you were called by the spirits hello
where are your spirit guys you have to
save the village
you need to be strong
we have to stop them
it is time for us to be brave yeah brave
wow
it's so beautiful
the jungle needs you
no rainbow
you are the whole
you just need to believe in yourself
i haven't helped anyone for a hundred
years so we need to save kendama it's me
and the jungle now
but even the greatest hunter can use a
little help
that's not a huge
you may not believe it
but there is magic
all around us
there are times it can be hard to find
did you bring your garbage to school
but sometimes
extra the magic finds us
look at you number casey so cute i'm so
red how big is he gonna get that depends
doesn't it unless
on how much you love him
i wish you were big and strong
and the world got nervous
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna be late for school
[Music]
or something it's new york don't even
notice
it's a just a big whoa why don't we get
you on the scale here bud
i'm just gonna write heavy
what if you found someone who made you
feel like you could do anything
[Music]
this
[Music]
well you don't see that every day maybe
it's time to feed it
[Music]
there's two kinds of people dad
the ones who have a bee bot
and the ones who don't hey guys oh sorry
i'm in your shot oh i have a filter for
that
really you need a bee bot to have a
social life yeah dad kind of i don't
want you addicted to some device
yeah though
hi barney i'm your best friend out of my
box
what are you doing
barney your bee bot is like super weird
i am barney's bee bop will you come to
my secret shed and like him
no no no
no
okay ron a bunch of your code is missing
you're supposed to know everything about
me hair brown height 411 511 would be
better girls would not laugh at you hey
making friends is what he's for friend
request friend request if he can't do
that he's like literally pointless oh
we'll get in trouble okay i cannot pull
his head off
i have no mega safety controls and stuff
copy him find that code
i'd better look into that you think
i'm not leaving you behind
they will send you to the crusher we'll
go to the crusher together no crushing
is not funny
not fun
where is it find the road we don't need
anyone else i currently have one friend
that is sad and also tragic
both of you here's where i can see them
[Music]
maybe turn it off and on again
[Music]
when all hope seems lost
when heroes
are needed more than ever
our fate is in there
pause a dog actually sir i'm a puppy
that's even worse you're in shock so i'm
not gonna take that personally this
summer another perfect rescue the
worldwide phenomenon
will be unleashed on the big screen
paw patrol what's your emergency my name
is liberty we need your help humdinger
he's going to destroy adventure city
come on pups adventure city's in trouble
[Music]
welcome to our new headquarters
this is so cool
there's even a new and improved puff
treat dispenser
what it's a beautiful thing
no dog by order of the new mayor
he's more of a cat person ladies and
gentlemen and most importantly
influencers with over 10 000 followers
we've got to rescue those people let's
get to work
paw patrol is on a roll are you kidding
me
i got this get out of the way move
you got to know how to talk to people
now go
[Music]
let's kick the tires and fight some
fires
this is what we do no cities too big
no pups too small
the boy wedding
[Music]
welcome
king james
i'm a cartoon
i'm sort of kevin hart
no no no no no no no no
what's up doc
bring it here man
what brings you to tone war doc
the computer dude kidnapped my son
what in the matrix hell
hey what'd you do to my son
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball you want to play me in
basketball
i need to assemble the league team
you need a dream team i'll take it from
here sam shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we we'll get
your son back
i promise
what's happening
i'm not a betting duck but my money's on
the other team
of the gym
your king
you're about to lose your family
in my head
everything you love well at least we're
good
oh and i almost forgot all of the tunes
will be deleted so
come on guys the toon squad doesn't give
up if we're going out we're going out
looney
you gotta win this game and get our son
back
up the chair let's go twos i got cops
coming off the bench
widely coyote
the machines producing multiple riley
coyotes
[Applause]
well that happened
[Music]
we need a boost a secret weapon come on
man granny's out here having a martini
at halftime kate is gonna hate
is anyone hungry yeah starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing well la
dee da i didn't realize i was with a
bunch of sophisticates
families can come in all shapes and
sizes that's why i also feature having
some two-legged children join them roll
it imagine me and our future children
frolicking
this is fun i'm speeding up a little i'm
speeding up quite a bit
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregor's i swear
if it wasn't for me peter just leave my
tomatoes alone you have everything else
honestly my kids will be so much better
behaved go easy on him as soon as they
have a baby we're done for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on the horizon and
just lock your eyes onto that
i love this place
what's for lunch there's a magical place
with the ripest radishes the sweetest
corn it's called
the farmer's market
and if you want an overpriced gift that
will never be used they shell lavender
scented bath bombs this sounds a bit
dodgy i would never put you in danger i
promise
okay i can't promise we're gonna go and
rob this place are you out
we're in
run
let them go my family's in trouble
and i'm gonna get them back
the other rabbits were taken and the pig
and the hedgehog and the badger
let's go get the others
why are you even helping me that's what
a dad does
[Music]
oh no cottontail just discovered sugar
we had a good run
i'm gonna live forever
tell you
[Music]
we can go anywhere
do anything
we just gotta stick together
we underdogs have to look out for each
other right underdogs
this is gonna be the best summer ever
[Music]
we'll write down every road
see the whole world together
[Music]
it'll be amazing
[Music]
but there's just one thing
wait did you see that no one can find
out
[Music]
where did you boys say you were from
[Music]
you are not going to get away with that
no
good night good night dad
you're behind your dream stage it's
completely off limits for all dreamers
the dream stages are real
wow you can actually change people
through their dreams
why did they have to move in with us
don't you want to be a real family again
there's literally no insta here omg omg
my new steps is come on selfie time
jenny has more than a thousand followers
nice
that is so gross tomorrow i'll make sure
my mom removes that thing i always get
what i want
three two one don't wake me up she wants
to put my hamster in an animal shelter
maybe i could tinker a tiny little bit
with her dreams
[Music]
so this will not end well
i'll fix it
well that was a lot of shambles
i mean how am i supposed to whack in
this heat these conditions
[Music]
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't trust anyone
hey
baby
where are your parents hey uh who's baby
really a con baby
[Music]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up
my name is raya our lands have been at
war for as long as we can remember our
people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again but someone has to
take the first step now in order to
restore peace we must find the last
dragon
i wish to join this fellowship of butt
hickory
let's go
we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching
please let this be it
who said that
we really need your help ah i'm gonna be
real with you i'm not like the best
dragon have you ever done like a group
project but there's like that one kid
who didn't pitch in as much but still
ended up with the same grave
uh we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
good
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just changed dragons can do that look
how close my butt is to my head it's
gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premiere access march 5th
who is coming to my birthday party what
about rapunzel and don't tell me she's
getting her hair done nope writing
something called a book sleeping beauty
says she has insomnia princess cruise
that's a ship sir princess leia she's a
general man i demand a glorious guess
then may i suggest inviting this young
lady
finally this horrible crone gets it
once upon a time there lived a princess
named snow white
but this fairy tale is about to get
a whole new twist
we need to find the most beautifulest
woman to kiss us and reverse the curse
what was that it's a witch let's catch
her and make her break the spell
oh my gosh what what happened to me i
mean my face and my waist um is that
really what i look like in the mirror i
think i hit her too hard
your power has drained you i don't have
much time prince find her
why are they after you it's my shoes
they're magical attention idiots straws
oh it's that loser prince average ah voo
raj ah please charge
featuring the voices of chloe grace
morris sam claflin gina gershon and
patrick warburton i can't wait for you
to see the real me i like you just as
you are
oh you had a thing on your cheek
your true self you're amazing on the
outside and the inside is the fairest of
them all
this is where your fairy tales
[Music]
i shall
return on tuesday no wait check my
calendar
thursday you got to be kidding me great
shoes and the seven dwarves
[Music]
fire drake stay out of trouble
what was that
humans i've always told you they're the
worst what will they do when they find
them
the rim of heaven huh
a paradise for dragons we could go there
and lead everyone to safety how are you
planning to get that i've got wings
haven't i
inspired by cornelia funka's
best-selling book so genius where do we
start
hi
[Music]
you're him yeah climb aboard dragon
rider
all humans are liars and chiefs you're a
fake you're not a dragon biter
[Music]
was that
my pants yes tell them who you are
likes golf and easy dragons
i just saw a juicy silver dragon
hunger for a silver dragon let's get out
of here
[Applause]
look at us both roaring
many have searched but no one has found
the rim of heaven who's hungry that's
not the time for depressment i'm trying
to be mystical
it was an arranged marriage you are much
more than you think you are follow your
heart and the truth will come to you
ready
ready
join a gang of unlikely friends
[Music]
yep
dragon rider
so we're two next partners
coming soon
[Music]
happy birthday mr adult man oh my god
what was dad like his beard was scratchy
he had a goofy laugh i wish i'd met him
i have something for you from your dad
it's a wizard stat
i wrote this spell so i could see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back like
back to life he wanted to meet you more
than anything
holy tooth of zadar how did you i don't
know it just started
hang
on dad
stood up bart dad you are in your house
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad
we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean corey she's
over there quick somebody help me these
griffin nuggets were supposed to go out
minutes ago that's the man's decor
you guys are in trouble big time get in
the vehicle i'm escorting you home i'm
giving you to the count of three
[Music]
uh okay wait what are you doing i don't
know
i'm looking for my sons oh they went on
a quest but don't worry i told him about
the map i told him about the gym i told
him about the curse huh i forgot to tell
him about the cars what
your boys are in grave danger
hold on
[Applause]
how are your boys doing a crisis
oh no
we're dead we're dead we're dead not
great
i can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this i believe in you
my gut knows where to go don't you boy
yes you do
i am on my way boys just stay out of
trouble
[Music]
disney and pixar seoul streaming on
disney plus december 25th
music is all i think about
from the moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born to play
it's my reason for living
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
is a soul missing
is this heaven no
is it h e
double hockey sticks how how hell quiet
coyote
no it's the great before
this is where new souls get their
personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth here we are
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
whoa
it's my life
can you help me get back come
on won't be a disaster
that's for sure
you're out there somewhere
and i'm gonna find you
life is full of possibilities
you just need to know where to look
[Music]
don't miss out on the joys of life
like
pizza
i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch
see
okay i get it
disney and pixar's soul
get ready your life is about to start
start streaming december 25th
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies you can't count on
me like one two three
tom and jerry are about to start over
cause that's what friends are supposed
to do
[Music]
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings and
we're about to host the wedding of the
century
do you think you're qualified to take on
this position i shine under pressure
like a diamond or rihanna
one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now
oh wow this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage millions of years of predatory
evolution
[Applause]
if a picture of these mouse is tweeted
up to insta book face or ticky talk we
will be ruined
no sir that's not gonna happen that
rodent is toast
[Music]
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat and a mouth
he's dying with us
i think i might have just pulled this
house off bouncy bouncy
oh
it's about to start you ready ready
popcorn button nachos cheese root beer
with red licorice straw right here
maybe it's time we made our new movie
good idea scoob but first we need a
trailer oh can you do the trailer guy
voice hmm well let me give it a shot
in a world destroyed by evil
discover the epic origin story
of the greatest team of heroes
in the history
of mystery
[Music]
nailed
[Music]
it this mangy strays coming with me he's
not a stray okay then what's his name
his name's
scooby middle name doobie last name
do
you that we would always be
without you i feel lost
i love it
i'll never take him off
uh maybe don't do that again
i'm fred this is velma hi and that's
daphne hey i'm shaggy and this is scooby
doo nice to meet you
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa shaggy and scooby were
taken
do you realize where we are no look
around man the clean modern aesthetic
the cool blue color palette we're in
mikey falcon fury did you say ikea nope
i said falcon terry just like you
maybe this can lead us to scooby and
shaggy trace amounts of mustache oil 12
year old scotch
is the bad guy my dad
we want to know everything about the man
we work for
the man
oh no this isn't about the father
this is about the sun
heart miss fowl
[Applause]
you've grown strong son
and smarter
than i ever imagined
then take me with you
you're all i have now arty
there's just one very important thing i
have to do
[Music]
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector he is suspected
to have been behind some of the biggest
robberies ever dad
hello your family has taken something of
great value from
us it to me or i will destroy everything
you love
[Applause]
you weren't supposed to see this yet
[Music]
your father is in a complicated
profession for years he has protected
powerful secrets that have kept mankind
safe from the dangers of another world
it's time to face your destiny
this is what they call greatness but we
are not alone in this mulch
just a talented giant dwarf and i'm
holly short your ally on the other side
it's real
all right save my father save the world
an army is coming
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm the next criminal
mastermind look around this is what they
call greatness i didn't read much on
trolls anything i should look out for
the teeth
they eat people good to know
but
it's time to shallow practice but it's
not holidays mom time to learn max and
lana are the best of friends if your
mother finds out let's go you're dead
when they meet the uglies
we're getting close now i can feel it
uh
green creatures we're the uglies what
life starts to get
funky
this place is perfect nothing but
wonderful smelly rubbish the oakleys eat
rubbish no wonder you don't want to dig
in
there's no way we can eat this
there is a crisis in smellyville with
the stench from the local rubbish dump
tourism at an all-time low it isn't just
tourists no one comes out much anymore
they seem to be some kind of natural
recyclers the uglies could save the town
just by being here what
these freaks have chosen the wrong place
to dig their homes
bye bye rubbish dumb hello wellness
temple they want to build a temple right
here
it's where the uglies live now we'll
have to leave again we can stop that
from happening this time hammer is
obviously up to something
let's follow and find out what i will be
so rich when we're done with this town
gentlemen start your bulldozers
[Music]
ugly baby needs some proper food
[Music]
[Music]
it was so great you came to town
welcome to smellyville a new day to
y'all
human
[Music]
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
[Music]
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish he'd get into some trouble
there's still time
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here
somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that
something's
[Music]
oh
coming
it's like the walking dead
we're ready to believe you
we're closed
[Music]
how's she doing
she barely speaks to me i don't need
your sympathy uncle john
that mustang's got a real mean streak
she's just angry
she was rounded up and taken away from
her family
what's her name
i haven't given her a name yet
[Music]
i heard you lost your family too
you really are beautiful
that's what i'll call you
black beauty
you've gotten closer to that philly days
than i have in weeks
they say horses pick you
the rescues have a time limit you can't
sell me
you're my family
you know that right
watch it go
watch
and i don't know
[Music]
saved my life you know how can a [ __ ]
save a person
[Music]
if i fought for every horse i'd ever
loved
i'd have a hundred of them
i don't want a hundred horses
i just want one
[Music]
shall i tell you a story
it's the story of an orphan girl
it was sent to live
in a mysterious house
if you cause me trouble i'll have you
sent away in an instant you understand
where she discovered something
something
magical
something
secret
but let me start at the beginning
[Music]
my name is mary lennox and my uncle owns
this house i'm colin craven and the
uncle you speak of is my father my
cousin
when's the last time you used your chair
i've never been able to walk we could go
outside who knows you might feel better
who are you i'm digging i need you to
keep a secret
why don't you just spat on yourself
if you are too much of a lady there is
no
i'm no lady sir
why can't i tell you i know of a magical
place capable of extraordinary things
i'd say that you were lying do you trust
me
you know what you risk
it's worth the risk
magic is on our side
once this house was filled with lights
laughter
happiness
this garden needs to kill colin
your excitement could kill him colin
needs to live this house
your son needs you
it's beautiful
magic
secrets
[Music]
remember what we talked about i don't
want to get a call from this new school
telling us that you've developed some
sort of chicken expanding rain
[Applause]
sorry about that
welcome to cranston academy look at this
place from the creators of the nut job 2
and escape from planet earth i'd like to
introduce you to danny dawkins
thanks a lot genius danny dawkins is
about to discover
[Music]
another world
well that was monumental
who are you i guess you can call me
mothman what kind of alien language is
that
there are monsters everywhere bulge was
getting bigger that means bigger
monsters can come out how much bigger
can they get
[Music]
get ready to fight the monsters
save the school if anyone can stop these
things it's the smartest kids in the
world
and be a hero
you okay i admit that plan wasn't fully
thought out featuring the voices of
jamie bell and ruby rose let's do this
zone
you didn't see nothing
[Music]
i'm just not that good with people
there is one thing i'm good at
[Music]
the mission was to find out what they
knew but that's kind of difficult now
that you killed everyone
i just don't think you're cut out for
the intelligence this is your last shot
how's school going oh my god you have
jelly all over your face i'm definitely
posting that on insta is it too late to
homeschool me
her
make it look like an accident yeah maybe
the stairs what wow still recording
we can cut a deal i want you to teach me
how to be a spy just to be clear this is
a one-time arrangement never again i
can't promise so what's first shooting
range obstacle course or to walk away
from an explosion a lie detector test i
can smell a lie endorphins release an
odor in the ultimate tell slightest
blink of an eye anything like this jj i
admire all of your tattoos
jj i believe you that you've never taken
steroids
damn she's good
when you look out there what do you see
90 civilians minimal security soft
perimeter smiling people having fun you
should try it
[Music]
[Applause]
the objective of this exercise is to get
past me a good idea might be to cause a
distraction because otherwise there'd be
zero chance that you'd be
blue
i'm just like exterior
you're a nice guy
what is he doing this looks like the
wedding at the end of shrek i just wanna
break the rules
[Music]
[Music]
everything will stay the same
cause the dreams bring back
[Music]
let's give him a great show okay i won
and only
why do they want an angry gorilla anyway
you're a silverback he terrified humans
oh
you're not terrifying
that
my sister where's your sister now
i don't remember
memories never leave us
they just get out of reach
whoa did you draw all these a gorilla
who draws
what is it don't tell me don't tell me
it's a lonely haystack on a late summer
day
it's a beetle
can you tell me a story
once there was a baby elephant who was
smart and brave and she needed to live
in the wild where she could be free
[Music]
does the baby elephant get to be free
[Music]
this painting is clearly a sign he wants
to be free
what about mac he's taking care of me my
whole life we're family
we're in this together
[Music]
for one and only
even
[Music]
i'll just cross the road then why would
you cross the road to get to the other
side
[Music]
you